Let's look at the solution to our latest
virtual to physical translation quiz,
where we had the memory access times and
the hit rates for the cache, and
we were assuming that
the three-level page table
now can be cached just like
data with the same hit rate.
Now we have one cycle to compute
the virtual address, followed by,
for each level of the page table,
three times, we need to do
one cycle to access the cache plus
10% of the time for each of those.
We will have a miss and go to memory
to fetch the page table entry.
And then after we do that, We can
access the data, which takes one cycle
plus 10% of the time, it takes
ten more cycles to access memory.
So now we have nine cycles altogether,
six of which are used by virtual
to physical translation.
And only three for
the instruction itself and
the memory access, including the misses.
So we can see that the virtual to
physical translation is expensive,
even if we allow page table entries
to be treated as data and cached.